chin might why is that door locked his
why am i dizzy I'm dizzy to put on my
drink
dude he's gonna gas it and then he's
gonna freeze us and then it's gonna eNOS
either
what part of the but if you first of all
you probably want to eat Brennan more
than me because he's good younger meat
right fresher it's not as to have any
diseases yeah and also here's me yeah I
wouldn't eat psoriasis me and you want
to eat my dick like it was eel besides
his dick what part would you eat first
survival situation yeah sure whatever
you want to call it I survive I mean
Tuesday afternoon yeah Tuesday afternoon
when you're horny and hungry if we
crashed in a plane and there's just no
other food and he passed away just like
that movie and we agreed on it maybe or
he or he was like I can't
I've got and you're like pinned under
all this machinery when you come here in
that mouth and nose how'd you do Tim I
probably go for thighs right thighs it'd
be a good one they say most the meats in
your glutes yeah that's just now you
have to work out in the dark meat of my
[ __ ] I'm not doing that
you trying to survive or not bro you're
hilarious that that's what you would eat
there is no question what I would honey
get your stupid cheat I would why they'd
be rubber this will be soft absolutely
more what's the cheeto porch II know
you're my chin tried make me that cream
barbecue the two T's are stupid old 51
year old cheese no you will disgusting
goddess not deep-fry your old fat nose I
don't know it isn't old fat nose it's a
lot so it probably tastes like you don't
worry no it'd be a calamari bro ah I
would take the two strips that go up
your back that that support your spine
that's tough meat that's that that's
also where to eat one on a deer that's
flank ax right
that's flanks it's not flank steak let's
flank no my flanks bro no thanks not a
human that's plate
I believe that's your that your flag bro
that's the back and that's the back back
steak right thanks bro you're like is
your ass no bro on a human flight cause
you ain't the where the flank steak is
booty my flame
I don't tough that meters and win just
but I were there's no fat got it I'd cut
it into like jerky like round round
dollar round large pancake size yeah see
there's the flank the bottom you
couldn't be more wrong
we were so off I be eating the sirloin
and the well I had the Tenderloin that's
right it's the Tenderloin yeah that I be
eating the tenderloin and that's a
beautiful shot James what do you Marion
this stuff be John James it was all from
like Stadium songs yeah well if I won
sure cat you're way too young for jock
jams if you're an athlete you'd was
still before games or something oh yeah
all the songs from the stadium yeah
whoop there it is it's just all in there
it was all these hits then Chuck I just
put on my CD player and go walk into
school say get the [ __ ] McNichols
arena
oh all right will ya guys oh yeah all
right just a couple two gays there we go
it's a big bear in his little twink
there we go boys yeah
yeah oh wow wills shorts just yelled fun
oh the listeners the will and grind
they're fighting fighting
Brian's hit him really hard really hard
and then we'll just lift in there and
he's oh he just spiked them down and
Brian hit his heel oh no I'll make out
with him oh yeah I like your shirt out
blocked
good luck thanks sir that's nice okay
I'm Colonel Matthew some career vets
that's called the murders I was at a
pumpkin patch and stone chin it's normal
for you there with a kid
there's grown men there by themselves
it's problem right cuz they're there
trolling for kiddies in my something is
going down are you doing i buy my kid
hippos I rest my kid has soccer um
carnival and his parents and kids
everywhere and then I just see a giant
like an oblong man just a big giant
oblong human being just boom boom with a
head nothing fit on his body was it me
he looked like a kid at putting together
from like a Lego set in Santa Monica at
3 p.m. because there's me know your
proportion this guy had this weird and
he was walking around alone look in the
fan swivel swivel head and his head was
on a swivel just looking at all the kids
know like they're a [ __ ] cotton candy
yeah and I walked up and I went hey bro
and he goes what I go you want to take a
walk or do you want me to make you take
a walk and then he go oh yeah I think
you're lying
no and then he goes you I guess you're
gonna have to make me take a walk and I
go you don't want this dude and he goes
I do and he was really big and then you
suck him off so many times he goes look
at kids it's a freak
Chango not around here and he goes then
I go get out of here and he goes wait
you're Bryan Callen from the Goldbergs
aren't you like I am thank you so much
now we became friends that make sense
what's up with your shoes what is that
did the male cheerleaders it's Super
Bowl four where those Dallas Cowboy the
Boosters the guys who would shut the
girls up in the air go VIN better they
had in the NFL
up until Super Bowl four when they
realized hey no one wants to see these
guys toss girls in the air well just
have the girls dance around a pump well
how do you feel so sorry Brian you're
fired
well can I keep my shoes Super Bowl four
[ __ ] off the expense
those are Dallas Cowboys those were made
in Austin Texas in 1969 because you're
them at Super Bowl four no when you were
tossing girls in the air and holding
their foot and putting your other hand
on their Fanny and they go yay
rah-rah-sis-boom-bah and you kept I did
Shirley all right I was an athlete
we low-energy this Monday I feel like
nothing hello you got nothing uh I got
nothing happened like you asked me what
I did this weekend I didn't I never got
me anything but I asked you you did I
can't remember a goddamn thing
well that's because all my friends are
gone you're not around gotta be with the
family never see Rogan yeah and then I'm
with the kids though you know so that's
what happens I mean it's not like it's
not like nowadays what are you gonna do
you gonna go out to dinner it's not like
we that we went to this party with Ray
like you know no I mean I can't go and
I'm self-conscious at 50 to go I
wouldn't go to a club no let me get a
table you was acknowledged it's tough to
get me to even go out like I like you're
like Drake's in town I just when I'm at
I just want to go home I just want to go
home man yeah I work all day and then I
leave town Thursday to Utah yeah let me
home one of my fights is getting all
dude getting old took my
Papa Papa job to box and burn and I do
those cardio class the dad do the car to
class he's sure walked in so I went [ __ ]
this noise alright you just did
something that I can't do no interested
I don't like any kind of a class like
that same here jogging spin you know see
people in groups jogging or biking it's
just not no it's not for me I'm a team
stuff has always been like I you know in
corporate retreats where they do these
trust exercises where you fall into each
others arms I guess it's good for
cohesion but I remember I've never
forgotten college I was thrown a
basketball against a wall in my dorm
miserable it's [ __ ] in DC in this
dorm like [ __ ] am i and these guys
combined a he's kind of kind of slick
looking dudes they had like one guy had
a Rolex on and he had kind of you know
the quaffed
well well quaffed like if if if I found
that they both had got their nails done
I wouldn't have been surprised they
looked very shiny shook my angers you
knew huh I got ya and he goes want you
pledged for us for sure you look like
you'd like to pledge I was like nope I
don't
you don't think where the meeting is so
I cannot go so yeah because I would
watch them I don't know if you had this
I'm sure you have this in your college
but you'd watch these pledges and they'd
have to do crazy [ __ ] let make it drunk
and they'd be like brothers for life no
frat well but when you're probably the
football team that's kind of like your
own Club you're probably what frat yeah
yeah you're in a different there's all
them together right around we only hung
out with each other and party it's a
sort of a fraternity yeah not as douchey
but it is bonding when you play football
right cuz but I like doing the classes
more excited private training forever
it's the classes are good cuz any other
people in there to push it you know yeah
a little competitive yeah you don't want
that [ __ ] know give some was singing
your praises by the way oh yeah yeah he
was he was a pretty cool treat her in a
way that's kind of a pretty that's a
good marker in your career when Mel
Gibson is talking about how good you are
that's nice yeah you know that [ __ ] Mel
Gibson that's what I say to him you
no [ __ ] no my I'll tell you my Mel
Gibson and iron pretty much every scene
together and so they would like
sometimes they I tell you this sometimes
break us for lunch at the same time and
my favorite thing was one day one day we
just went to lunch early so we're
sitting there talking about whatever and
there was like they were doing like you
know you know like [ __ ] steak and
[ __ ] over there and Joe has a wonderful
wonderful setup and so at any rate cut
to us sitting there and I'm like digging
into my steak and we both either the
same way really wrong how Rawls dude ah
I mean like when you go cog oh I want to
blue on the inside charred on the
outside I want it my crispy on the
outside SP on the outside lukewarm in
the middle mmm
yeah it could be even a little yeah
whole like room Wow do means it's pretty
good she in the middle I want to sue she
like like a barn fire started and it's a
thousand degrees and a cow runs in there
to save her calf real quick and get out
and then gets out and just like is
totally wrong an outsider has is that
fifth degree burns no that's too much
for will really was I need that I
wouldn't send that one back you would be
happy but me nobody happy though you
mean that might be a little too cooked
that's a little too you're you're like
that's getting there now we're talking
now we're getting there you're like
Tommy Lee Jones in under siege we go
that no no more money yeah that more
well that's medium rare I like mine rare
there we are that that looks like I
cooked it that looks exactly like I
cooked and he'd take it you take it
super raw in the middle
yeah you and you and Mel Gibson's the
steak that way and bonded over and he
was and he was eating it he was ripping
it apart like an animal like just just
would like rip off a piece because it
was so perfectly rare and we just saying
and we'd be talking and think and so
pretty soon I put down my fork and knife
and I'm like I got I got the okay to go
hand yeah
I like everyone goes [ __ ] you like well
me and Brian eating sushi is it the
right thing to do no but Brian will take
his [ __ ] hands and just grab the
whole thing like a bonbon and
and it's so much easier yeah I just
popping them I started doing that's when
you know that's when you know you're
friends with someone when you can go and
you do that eat at a BBQ place and get
[ __ ] out and get off yeah get it
everywhere what one would you say you
don't know a little brisket and a
dicksuck I'm afraid
wait no hold on a second no because you
said I was just saying you could get
messy while eating and then you said
something you said you said you said
[ __ ] right you said and [ __ ] afterwards
and some yes right hip and ass play I
know that's what you know I was saying
don't blame it on him don't blame anyone
what did you say I said you could I
barely got it out I said you know you
can eat with your friends you can get
messy right and that's exactly what you
said I was finishing what your sin
tonight do you know I just haven't
barbecue then you want to have bark Ian
[ __ ] you no because I heard you go and
and then I so I finish the sentence well
okay all right anyway well now this is
the now they're not about Mel Gibson in
the way all right when you see my back
ripple and I pull myself up like a champ
like a chimp thirty times fast
while talking to you why wouldn't I give
that to you as it's a gif it's a gift
it's a gift